sickness and death are facts of human
existence even today in the world of
modern medicine from Ebola outbreaks in
Africa to SARS in Asia and the West Nile
virus more mundane but equally
problematic are the recurring flu
outbreaks that sicken large segments of
the population every few years disease
outbreaks epidemics and pandemics all
can and have had profound effects on
humans upsetting population growth
social norms religious beliefs and not
surprisingly the economy the immediate
effects of epidemics often include
shutdowns in trade and travel routes
lower economic productivity disruption
in the supply and demand of goods and in
extreme cases demographic crisis
consider the Black Death one of the most
devastating epidemics in history and the
impact it had on late medieval society
and its economy black death is a modern
term for the plague academic that
devastated much of Eurasia during the
middle of the 14th century in popular
culture it was often associated in
Europe with the imagery of the book of
Revelation in the Christian Bible let's
consider one of the many illustrations
of the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
for example as described in the book of
Revelation one is the well-known woodcut
of Albrecht Durer printed at the end of
the 15th century well after the plague
hit the Horseman represented conquest
war famine and death and they heralded
the end of the world in the late
medieval economy the prophecies were
evident to all particularly once the
last of the four horsemen death astride
his Pale Horse unleashed the sword
famine pestilence and wild beasts to
kill forth of the earth as the middle of
the 14th century approach it looked to
many like the end was near but let's
move away from popular imagery and take
a closer look at the events that made up
this greatest Christ
of the 14th century events that had so
many in the society worried that the end
of time might be approaching by the end
of the 13th century
the climate was already changing in a
period of cooling began this cycle of
cooling lasted for a few hundred years
and is often referred to as the Little
Ice Age the climatic changes led to many
years of crop failures and ultimately
famine in many parts of Europe and that
resulted in chronic malnutrition and
emic warfare exacerbated the problems of
poor harvests and contributed to the
longevity of famines indeed it was
warfare in the Black Sea town of Kepha
on the Crimean Peninsula that probably
introduced the plague into Europe this
was at a time when the European
population was already reeling from
climate change warfare and famine the
resulting demographic crisis was
catastrophic in the Middle Ages which
extends approximately from the 5th to
the 15th centuries the climate initially
underwent a period of warming that
benefited agricultural productivity for
sure with the technologies and
agricultural knowledge of the time
agricultural productivity was always
rather low and even in good times
European agriculture was tenuous at best
chronicles abound the tale of good years
followed by bad and Europeans often
seemed short of food but for the most
part for hundreds of years
Europe had escaped the severe famines
and crop shortages would have resulted
in widespread starvation the result was
steady and even robust population growth
before the 14th century but the growing
population required even more food this
led to increasing production on land
that have already been intensely
exploited for agriculture and also to
marginal land being brought under
cultivation lands that could not produce
crops under less than ideal
circumstances an agricultural output
increased
but because population was also
increasing there were no real surpluses
so by the first decade of the 14th
century when cool temperatures and very
wet growing seasons had become
increasingly common a crisis in
agriculture was blueing dat brewing the
first signs of trouble occurred in
southwest germany when the wheat crop
failed in 1309 heavy cold rains hit
europe in the following years
this intensified in 1315 and continued
to plague the continent through at least
13 18 and for several more years in some
parts the rains oversaturated crop lands
to the point that crop yields were in
1316 were half of normal levels and
productivity was barely enough to feed
the continent even during the good
year's crops didn't fail only because of
too much rain and bad weather the
climate was cooling to the point that
certain kinds of agriculture could no
longer be practiced in places where it
flourished before for example with a
cooler climate grape cultivation which
had flourished during much of the Middle
Ages disappeared in England farther to
the north in parts of Scandinavia the
growing season was no longer long enough
to support grain cultivation the result
of these shocks was the Great Famine
during the worst of the famine the
summer of 13 16 some areas such as parts
of Flanders in Great Britain saw a five
to ten percent of their populations die
of starvation the people of the times
described the hardships in stark terms
John de truc lo wrote quote the summer
rains were so heavy the grain could
hardly ripen it could hardly be gathered
and be used to bake bread unless it was
first put in vessels to dry around the
end of autumn the dearth was mitigated
in part but toward Christmas it became
as bad as before bread did not have its
usual nourishing power and strength
the grain was not nourished by the
warmth of the summer sunshine hence
those who ate it even in large
quantities were hungry again after a
little while there can be no doubt that
the poor wasted away when even the rich
were constantly hungry and a quote to be
sure some areas suffered more than
others and the types of disruption
varied as well while grain crops were a
problem all over some areas experienced
livestock academics during the same
period the devastation in livestock
numbers resulted in higher livestock
prices as supply fell dramatically year
after year until about thirteen twenty
or even 1322 European agriculture could
not feed its population various famines
occurred in some parts of the continent
as late as the 1330s and 1340s
and some of these were due to livestock
epidemics decimating the meat supply
large numbers of people died of
starvation and disease those who lived
often suffered from chronic malnutrition
not surprisingly grain prices rose
astronomically during the worst of the
famine years that is about 13 15 to 13
18 by about 10 times their pre famine
prices once the famine abated grain
prices declined Western Europeans had
tapped into the grain producing areas of
Eastern Europe and the grain rich
regions around the Black Sea the Ukraine
Crimea and the Balkans European
merchants and especially the Italians
flooded the market with cheap grain from
the east and with grain prices low many
European farmers turned to alternative
crops that could fetch higher prices
farmers near large cities often turn to
what we now refer to as truck farming
the production of fruits and vegetables
transported to market for local
consumption the crises of the early
14th century had forced an almost
complete restructuring of medieval
agriculture but there were other shocks
that also contributed to the crisis a
series of Wars broke out between 1337
and the late 15th century these
conflicts were very different from those
that had come before in Europe most
medieval Wars consisted of infrequent
battles between small armies drawn
mostly from the elites in society and
they were waged primarily during the
summer season Knights fought these older
medieval battles and in general the
population was not too troubled by them
for the most part by contrast the Wars
of Western Europe in the 14th and 15th
centuries were very different armies
engaged in multiple campaigns that made
battlefields out of farm fields in
almost every year and as soldiering
became a professional occupation at the
end of the Middle Ages the prolongation
of war was in their best interest the
new professional class of soldiers was
often either badly compensated or left
unpaid so that individual warriors and
combatants were forced to live off the
countryside taking what they needed to
survive from the farms of the region the
regular destruction of crops and the
effects of the destruction of mills and
barns not to mention the pillaging of
soldiers became common throughout the
late Middle Ages the countryside bore
the brunt of these armed skirmishes and
plunder cities and towns had some
protection because of their walls the
peasants in the countryside however were
at the mercy of the armies living off
the land so the destruction of crops and
supporting industries devastated an
already weakened agricultural systems
ability to provide for the population
more than that the systematic
destruction
of aristocratic wealth during the
periods of war and remember wealth was
largely measured in terms of
agricultural production became a
military tactic by the 14th century if
the loss of life resulting from war
weren't bad enough the systematic
destruction of agricultural wealth could
significantly alter the rural economy
particularly when it occurred over
prolonged periods of time for example in
one small area of Flanders in 1302
twenty-two barns and seven grain build
men bills were burned in France at the
monastery of Santini the monks sold 133
modes
that's a dry measure for grain in 1343
decades later that same amount of land
produced only four modes because of the
depredations of war of course as soon as
the armies moved on villages repaired
and rebuilt the agricultural
infrastructure but the damage certainly
exacerbated problems associated with
with that other problem I mentioned a
changing climate
the best known example of this new kind
of devastating warfare was the long
conflict between the kings of England
and the kings of France called the
Hundred Years War it lasted from about
1337 to 1453 and although the war was
not continuous military campaigns were
fought off and on during much of this
time the Hundred Years War began as a
private conflict between rivals for the
throne of France one of whom was also
the King of England by the time it ended
however it had become a modern war
affecting the people of both countries
and drawing other countries into it more
importantly for our purposes it
exacerbated the crises the devastated
large swathes of northwestern Europe
during the first half of the 14th
century
at first the Hundred Years War emerged
as an outgrowth of the civil war that
was raging in Flanders the French King
had captured the county of Flanders in
1302 but the Flemish towns rose in
revolt and massacred French Garrison's
in several towns off and on for the next
few decades the Hundred Years War
focused on Flanders by the 1340s however
it had moved into the grain-rich Duchy
of Normandy in northern France
when Edward the 3rd of England invaded
this phase of the war culminated in the
great French defeat at crécy in the
summer of 1346 when a smaller English
force vanquished the French cavalry
northwestern Europe wasn't the only part
of the continent to be ravaged civil
wars tormented the italian peninsula and
the German lands descended into
political turmoil in addition revolts
and insurrections in the countryside and
especially in the towns further
exacerbated the situation in the
countryside peasants often found
themselves at odds with their lords who
restricted the use of common pastures
and forests and burdened them with
labour dues in the towns artisans rose
up against the upper class in control of
town government as the first half of the
14th century du drew to a close
much of Europe had experienced
successive waves of poor harvests and
famine the population was further beaten
down by warfare on a large scale
especially in northwestern Europe due to
the Hundred Years War and civil strife
over large areas of the continent then
seemingly out of nowhere plague attacked
too many it seemed like the judgment of
God was being hurled at mankind about
ten years after the great famine struck
Europe with a vengeance and just as the
battles that led up to the Hundred Years
War were getting underway in Flanders
a devastating plague was emerging far
away in the south of China some accounts
from the 1330s reported massive
population losses in China perhaps as
high as 90 percent of the population in
a few places like the City of Hope a
estimates suggest that by 1350 one China
had lost between 1/2 and 2/3 of its
population to plague rodent fleas
transmitted the sickness from its point
of origin in the mountainous Central
Asian steppes which had regular
commercial interactions with southern
China thanks to the Mongols rodents
especially rats were everywhere in the
cities of southern China not something
most people would have thought much
about but China was an important source
of goods that were exchanged all over a
year Asia and across the Mongol Empire
and the rodents with their fleas made
happy homes in the warehouses and
transfer stations all along the trade
routes of the Silk Road that crossed
Central Asia and that linked East with
West it is highly likely that Mongol
armies first introduced the plague to
the Chinese city of hope a early in the
14th century
hope-a seems to have been the focus of
plague outbreaks for decades from hope-a
the illness might have spread to Fukien
by 1345 and then to Xiang tune young Chi
and Hunan among other places by the
1350s
the plague also reached the mongol
outposts on the shores of the Black Sea
by 1345 in 1346 the Khanate of the
Golden Horde a group of Mongols was
preparing to attack a Genoese trading
post in Crimea this was the fortified
port town of kapha that i mentioned at
the outset of this lecture the Genoese
were primarily engaged in the russian
slave trade which the mongols sometimes
supported and often opposed by the time
of the siege of cafe
the Mongol army had become infected with
the plague and spread it to the Genoese
colony in kapha
how exactly the disease was spread as a
matter of some speculation the story
that has gotten the most traction comes
from a lawyer of Piacenza who supposedly
heard it from some sailors years later
in this account the Mongols catapulted
the bodies of dead plague victims over
the walls of kapha well not wanting
rotting bodies to pollute their city the
Genoese hauled off and dump them into
the sea thus unwittingly infecting
themselves once they departed kapha in
their ships they brought the plague with
them now unfortunately this is the only
account to provide such an explanation
for the transmission of plague to the
Genoese and it's extraordinarily
suspicious that the Mongols might have
catapulted dead bodies over the walls of
cafes and not outside the realm of
possibility but the likelihood of the
infectious bacterium surviving such an
ordeal is very low far more likely is
that rodents carrying infected fleas
infected the rodent population of kapha
and these infected rodents very well may
also have infected the shipboard rats or
possibly boarded the ships themselves
what the chroniclers of the 14th century
didn't realize was that a human host was
not necessary to spread the disease well
how the plague came to be ungenerous I'd
the point once the ships carrying their
deadly car goes left kava for the busy
commercial ports of the Mediterranean
there was no stopping the disease from
spreading
what kind of disease was this it is rare
to hear of anyone dying from the plague
today modern antibiotics keep it under
control in areas where it still exists
but the black death was terrifyingly
deadly for a population that didn't
understand how disease spreads it
actually represents three forms of
plague the three types of plague are
bubonic
mnemonic and septicaemia of these the
bubonic plague was the most common form
as I indicated the bubonic plague is
usually spread by the bite from an
infected rodent flea as rodents die from
the infection
their fleas seek another source of food
animal blood and so they often jump to
other animals and to humans fleas were
quite common during the medieval period
so most people wouldn't have been much
concerned about the occasional flea bite
the incubation period of the bubonic
plague is about six days the period
between infection and the first symptoms
the initial symptom is a blackish
pustule forming over the point of the
flea bite followed by swollen lymph
nodes nearest the bite this is followed
by hemorrhaging under the skin which
produces bruise like purple blotches
called buboes on the victims skin it is
from this word booboo that the bubonic
plague gets his name the sub contain E
as' hemorrhaging affects the nervous
system which produces neurological and
psychological disorder such as delirium
and stupor bubonic plague is the least
toxic of the three types of plague but
it still kills between 50 and 60% of its
victims pneumonic plague is different
from bubonic plague in that it can be
spread from human to human after a 2 or
3 day incubation period the victim
suffers a sharp drop in body temperature
which is followed by severe coughing and
a subsequent discharge of blood in the
spud on this buttom contains the plague
bacteria making for an airborne
transition as in the bubonic plague
symptoms include neurological and
psychological disorders pneumonic plague
is rather rarer than the bubonic plague
but it's still fatal in over 95% of its
victims
the last and rarest
form the septicemia plague is like the
bubonic plague spread by fleas or by
handling the body fluids of plague
victims its distinguishing feature is
its rep initi death occurs within a day
of infection in many cases it's almost
always fatal well prior to the 14th
century the illness had last swept
through Europe in the Year 541 called
Justinian's plague then after Emperor
Justinian it was most active in the
Byzantine Empire and in the port cities
of the eastern Mediterranean now plague
sporadically cropped up in Eastern
Europe until about the 8th century but
from about the 8th century to the 14th
century Europe was plague free the major
diseases in Europe were smallpox and
measles and a few others but this was a
fairly stable disease pool but let's
return now to the Genoese ships that
brought the plague from kapha to western
europe constantinople known today as
Istanbul and Turkey was the capital of
the Byzantine Empire and an important
commercial port this was the first stop
the Genoa ships made on their way home
once infection passed into the busy port
city of Constantinople it was easily
transmitted along the maritime trade
routes to North Africa and the Middle
East and of course to the port towns in
Sicily and Italy it spread rapidly
through the Mediterranean by 1348 there
were outbreaks in Cairo Antioch and much
of southern Italy although the plague
moved quickly along the sea routes it
also travelled overland city rat
populations intermingled with country
rats and shared their infected fleas I
know this sounds funny but the old city
mouse country mouse stories hold some
truth more commonly livestock could
provide a host for fleas and herds were
often driven from town to the
countryside and then to other towns
plague could also travel with merchants
on
they're pack animals and in their goods
for example wool cloth provided a
temporary home for infected fleas the
Black Death came through the passes in
the Alps to Germany across the Rhine
from France and Holland and throughout
Europe France was probably the most
populated country in Western Europe in
the 14th century the plague entered
France via the Rhone River Valley trade
routes and the Black Death arrived in
Paris in 1348 at its peak Paris was
losing about 800 people a day to the
disease the Black Death is best
documented in Britain where it's
believed to arrived on ships from
Gascony it reached London in September
of 1348 like all medieval cities London
suffered from extremely poor sanitation
allowing the plague to ravage the city
for almost two years it killed roughly
40 percent of the city's population
before abating by 1349 the plague had
reached Bergen in Norway carried there
as near as we can tell on a shipment of
wool from London Bergen was a member of
the Hanseatic League and an important
North Sea port with regular trade to the
Baltic ports plague was particularly
severe in Scandinavia possibly because
the cold weather caused pulmonary
complications and facilitated the
pneumonic form of the disease the plague
killed half the population of
Scandinavia from Scandinavia the plague
moved along trade routes out into the
Atlantic
killing 60% of the population of Iceland
and by winter 1350 it reached
scandinavian settlements in Greenland
where it wiped out most of the surviving
population Eastern Europe was struck not
as violently by the plague as was
Western Europe by 1351 when the Black
Death was moving east along the rivers
and through the Baltic the epidemic was
2 and a half years old it is possible
that by then the underlying back
tyria had mutated into a less virulent
strain but geography might have also
played a role Bohemia which is the
modern Czech Republic is ringed by
mountains on its western and northern
borders and was not a major commercial
center the plague hardly affected
Bohemia at all neighboring Hungary
however lay on a plain that the Danube
River ran through and was hit much
harder so the plague circled Europe from
around 1350 to 1350 one finally reaching
southern Russia where it had first
entered Europe four years before exactly
how many people died from the plague is
it coerced through Europe as a matter of
speculation there were no census
population censuses so we don't even
know what the population of Europe was
before the Black Death mortality
estimates range from 25 to almost 60
percent of the Earth's population most
scholars feel a figure of between 40 to
50 percent is the best guess as I
mentioned earlier the plague also struck
hard in the Muslim world it hit
Alexandria in Egypt in 1347 almost
certainly introduced by Italian
merchants from the Black Sea plague
broke out in Cairo by the autumn of 1348
some sources suggest that by 1349
one-third of the total population and
perhaps 40 or 50 percent of the urban
population of Egypt had died the Black
Death ranks as one of the greatest
disasters of the Middle Ages and one
that affected much of the afro-eurasian
world it even touched north america in
the scandinavian settlements of
greenland the disasters of the 14th
century had long-term effects on much of
the world not only was population
reduced in a horrifying way across
Eurasia but the devastation and social
turmoil also resulted in restructuring
of society and economy the plague was a
devastating phenomenon and could not be
minimized
but the associated troubles that bore
down on Europe the famine persistent
warfare and civil strife and disease
resulted in a very different and perhaps
more resilient economy from what had
existed during most of the Middle Ages
but the value of labor to work the land
increased it was during this period that
entrepreneurial merchants who were not
bound to the land grew in influence the
rise of the Craft Guild succeeded in
paving the way for the development of a
capitalist system in which commerce
predominated the old equilibrium of
agricultural society where labor was
cheap and land deer had been turned on
its head in a matter of only a few years
before the Black Death Europe's
agricultural land was overburdened with
the farming technologies of the time
populations could not grow unless more
land was brought under cultivation the
number of people that a household could
support was limited by the amount of
farmland available households working
with five units of land or less could
not support more than about three or
four people while those with more than
about 20 units could support ten people
as we have seen any decrease in
production put enormous stress on the
population and made untenable the feudal
system in which serfs were bound to the
land once the plague wiped out large
percentages of the rural population this
stress was reduced as demand for land
decreased its value dropped
[Music]
you
[Music]